after the recession officially ended in
2009 the subsequent recovery was
significantly slowed by a variety of
persistent headwinds including
households with underwater mortgages and
high debt burdens reduced access to
credit for many potential borrowers
constrained spending by state and local
governments and weakened far in growth
prospects in an effort to return
employment and inflation to levels
consistent with the Federal Reserve's
dual mandate the FOMC took a variety of
unprecedented actions to lower long-term
interest rates including reducing the
federal funds rate that's the dotted
black line to near zero communicating to
the public that short-term interest
rates would likely stay exceptionally
low for some time and buying large
quantities of longer-term treasury debt
and agency issued mortgage-backed
securities these actions contributed to
highly accommodative financial
conditions thereby helping to bring
about a considerable improvement in
labor market conditions over time the
unemployment rate which peaked at ten
percent in 2009 is now five point one
percent that slightly above the median
of fomc participants current estimates
of its longer-run normal level although
other indicators suggest that the
unemployment rate currently under states
how much slack remains of the labor
market unbalanced the economy is no
longer far away from full employment in
contrast inflation has continued to run
below the committee's objective over the
past several years and over the past 12
months it has been essentially zero
nevertheless the committee expects that
inflation will
gradually turn return to two percent
over the next two or three years and I'd
like to now turn to the determinants of
inflation and the factors that underlie
this expectation models used to describe
and predict inflation commonly
distinguish between changes in food and
energy prices which enter total
inflation and movements in the prices of
other goods and services that's called
core inflation this decomposition is
useful because food and energy prices
can be extremely volatile with
fluctuations that often depend on
factors that are beyond the influence of
monetary policy such as technological or
political developments in the case of
energy prices or weather or disease in
the case of food prices as a result core
inflation usually provides a better
indicator than total inflation of where
total inflation is headed in the medium
term of course food and energy account
for a significant portion of household
budgets so the Federal Reserve's
inflation objective is defined in terms
of the overall change in consumer prices